you said that I'm Switzerland in World
War II since I'm friends with both you
and Gordon and John
uh rich country are you a Hitler or
Stalin by the way in this analogy would
you like to be Hitler or Stalin and
should you make a t-shirt out of it or I
mean a nasty t-shirt I don't know how
well that sells yeah I think it would
you know I think that let's brainstorm
on this one offline
I think since Hitler lost so you got
second place in World War II that's true
that makes you Hitler anyway uh in to
the degree that you can
can you tell the story of how the time
you've had with the Donna her death
squad and why he split up I competed
against Gordon for ADCC
and ebi in 2017 and I remember I
competed against my ADCC and then we had
the Ebola event and then I had a Kasai I
used to compete all the time every week
I wouldn't even do the prep preparation
or anything I'd just be like trying to
do seminars make money and then jump in
and compete I remember I showed up to
Kasai after I faced him twice and there
were like four locker rooms and they put
me with all the DDS guys it was just me
and all of DDS and I think we competed
the week weekend before so I thought it
was going to be super awkward but it was
actually it was actually pretty chill
and the Kasai was in New York and they
suggested to come train that week so I
came trained hung out with them a bit uh
ultimately the goal was to move to
America and join a bigger team just
because that flight to Australia's death
Australia is so far away from everywhere
it's kind of like not realistic to base
yourself in Australia when all the
tournaments are in America and then I
went and trained with guys and I just
had a massive uh massively deep talent
pool in that room like show up to like a
meant to be 7 A.M actual 8 A.M class uh
on Brazilian time it'd be like 100
people in there maybe I don't know how
many black belts but a ton of elite guys
and I was coming from Australia
um training with Lachlan Giles but
really that room was pretty shallow and
like most people had serious jobs and
stuff so it was like basically me just
trading with Lachlan maybe a couple of
other guys and then to go to New York
and have access to a a wide array of
trading partners and guys that are
training twice each day I feel like
that's what you really need you need
people that can train as much as you are
we're humbled
humbled in that room at first for sure
because my style at the time was
basically a rip-off version of what they
were doing yeah leg locks came in I
remember just watching Eddie Cummings
Non-Stop and just seeing this guy rip
people's legs off and I was like you
know what that's probably a good move
you know that looks like an easier path
to Victory than trying to beat these
guys at what they what they're good at
already you know My Philosophy at the
time was if it's bothering old
Brazilians yeah it's bothering them for
a reason yeah it's probably effective
and that's the path I took to sort of
try to rip off their moves and then
obviously to go into that room try to do
them to them it's going to be a bit more
difficult
all right so that's how it started
how did you end up here how do we end up
here we're in Austin Texas I mean I like
to think of Puerto Rico as Apocalypse
Now John danaher as Colonel Kurtz
things go very weird in the jungle
and the teams went into different
directions
but honestly I mean it's not really my
story to tell I had some uh issues with
some of those people at the time of the
split I got along very well with John I
feel like me and him connected very well
I don't know why that was maybe it was
just because of the he missed homie
missed a familiar accent Australian New
Zealand accent uh but I mean I basically
followed Nikki left with Nikki sort of
that Core group of guys left with Nikki
and I mean I just back there was
personal problems and I just backed
Nikki basically got it just sticking on
you for a bit is there a part of you
that you know finds it heartbreaking
that DDS split up this part of you
missed working with John and everybody
now can you still man the case for that
I mean I miss certain aspects of it but
I also do prefer the freedom of being
apart from it it's obviously a very
strict regime under John danaher you
know obviously as parts of her I miss
the past the public doesn't see of John
the behind the scenes bands I feel like
he's very conscious of the image he
portrays to the world but basically it
closed doors he's always making jokes
always finding I guess more in line with
the Australian kiwi sort of culture but
you don't really see that in the public
class so that perspective I do miss that
relationship with John in terms of
setting aside personal differences
Gordon was a good training partner
definitely a good training partner to
train with uh but obviously the negative
things we can't really talk about
outweighed all of those things and we
obviously had to make a decision
to leave but yes that happened in the
jungle the things happen in the jungle
shall never be spoken of but I
personally cannot speak up yeah but
obviously I do miss certain aspects like
I mean no nothing's all bad nothing's
all good you know
yeah this goes back to your like uh
everything we're doing is silly yeah
exactly that's why I didn't get people
to take it so serious martial arts so
serious just
it's just pretty stupid really
especially in the key it looks just
it looks bad and then I mean it's pretty
silly with with and without the ghee it
sounds a bunch of Apes what's silly
about no game what's silly about the
ghee and just mixed and mashed bottoms
there you know what I mean wait which
one
I see what you're doing
brother
you come to my house I defend my people
all right
you know this is we're gonna go to every
dark place apparently
um Nick how did you get with uh DDS like
what was that Journey like is there uh
try to see if there's things that you
remember finally that that you've uh
gotten from the experience all right so
the way I started um training with DDS
um initially I was training for like
well initially I was I was at a bouncer
right I was I dropped out of college to
pursue this uh Fitness modeling career I
ended up signing with a Willamina models
up in New York and I was like trying to
get in better shape and while I was
bouncing kind of the talk of like you
know who stuffer came up between the
wrestlers and a few of the bouncers to
train Jiu Jitsu and uh you know they
convinced me to go to a practice and and
I went to my first practice over there
and uh I for the most part I just
controlled everybody got on top of them
was able to avoid like kind of like you
know shitty submissions because I had I
had an awareness of the sport and you
know I'm a fan of fighting and whatnot
so um you know I kind of on stood it
pretty well and then soon after that I
joined a school and my second week of
Jiu Jitsu I started competing had pretty
good success you know I was like subbing
a few black belts and beating everybody
like you know pretty decisively with
points and stuff and about three months
into training locally I got connected
with uh Gordon Gordon Ryan and John
Denver up in New York and I started I
committed to you know make the drive up
there as many days as I could at the at
the time I lived in South Jersey and I
was about two and a half hour three hour
drive without traffic where in South
Jersey Gloucester County
um Clayton New Jersey specifically but
Gloucester County yeah so it was about
is about about 130 miles and without
traffic you know about and two two and a
half hours or so but on the way back man
we it'd be three plus sometimes you know
catching that Rush Hour what year was
this do you remember this was in 2018
for a bit I forget how young you are
yeah I was there before before all that
all right cool uh anyway you're doing
the long drive and then and then and
what yeah doing a long drive and then uh
you know once I won 80cc Charles was
able to make a couple bucks and then you
know I got my silver medal at 80cc and I
was able to afford to live up there in
New York in in North Jersey area so I
lived up there trained there full time
every day and uh it was kind of stuck
with the team throughout throughout the
turbulent times and found myself in
Austin in the jungle in the jungle the
other things we shall not speak of
what uh What uh are there things that
you remember that you've learned from
John donoher from your time you spent
with him yeah I mean I definitely
learned a ton from uh from John and the
team as a whole like uh you know it's
you have to be the guy that asks
questions in in the type of environment
right because there's not it's not
you're not going to get singled out to
be that specific uh like star or the the
best guy in the room when you have all
these other you know stud athletes so I
really have to seek out and and figure
out the kind of questions that I needed
to ask and um once I became a bit more
verbal with my training and you know uh
I I'm showing I'm I'm expressing all my
Curiosities about grappling to these
guys definitely help boost my uh boost
my technique and my career as a whole
yeah did you understand what kind of
stuff like technically you want to get
good at what fits your body what like
what would be good for you what what are
your weaknesses and all that so
initially when I started grappling I had
an innate ability to just get to
opponents back so I was like all right
I'm gonna get into the back let me get
let me perfect controlling the back and
then submitting opponent via naked choke
um and then besides that I really focus
on leg lock defense and then eventually
came the variety lock password you know
I'm uh I'm really good at body like
passing my opponents now and then and um
yeah just takes a quite a long time
because you have to find uh different
sequences and then there's always these
uh an abundance of opportunities that
your opponent gets from these specific
sequences so it takes a while
is there part of you that finds the fact
that DJs split up heartbreaking
um I definitely you know having one
person to go to that runs practice every
day that's you know consistent
um it was definitely it was definitely
definitely a gift but now I'm also
gifted with many many other partners
have Nikki Ryan
um you know Craig Jones
yeah yeah uh we have Ethan Cruella scene
Damian Anderson so a full team of
knowledgeable athletes that I can
continue to go to with uh multiple
questions but yeah definitely definitely
uh it took me some time to adjust to to
training or to learning from you know uh
specifically my team and not just one
person
we should mention for people just
listening because you can't visually see
that Nikki Ryan is currently terrified
and Craig Jones is currently enjoying
but anyway uh can you talk about your uh
Nikki can you talk about your time with
DDS I started training when I was like
around 13
um you know my brother Gordon had
started prior to me and uh I really just
went into training just as like a means
to exercise and lose weight at the
beginning because I was pretty fat as a
kid so I went to the first class loved
it and then just started training every
day at uh at Gary shrimp Brunswick and
then during the summer when I get off
from school they would take me up to New
York to uh to train under John
and you know I just absolutely loved it
I knew what I wanted to do with my life
at a young age so I ended up dropping
out of school actually after my my
freshman year in high school so yeah 15
I ended up dropping out and just
pursuing Jiu Jitsu full time uh you know
training every day up in the uh the blue
basement like what aspects of Jiu Jitsu
was
um made you know that this is the thing
for you it's just something I just
enjoyed being you know like on the mats
every day I love that there's you know a
problem solving aspect to it
um so it's you know it's mentally
challenging it's physically challenging
helps me get in shape so I just yeah
right off the bat I knew I loved it
okay so uh then we'll go to the Jungle
what happened in the jungle
and in general like uh
I like this I like this this is like
this like shroud of mystery that she'll
never be penetrated that should never be
like we've got a book deal it's coming
obviously left high school he's not
riding him
uh okay I'll do the Russian translation
okay
so what are what are things that you
enjoyed that you remember from working
with John Donahue yeah I mean you know
obviously he's considered one of the
best coaches in the world
um you know very charismatic guy when
you see him in person uh you know I
pretty much was you know kind of raised
in the DDS you know that's where I spent
the the majority of my time every day so
I obviously had very deep connections
you know with John my brother uh Gary
um you know even Eddie Cummings and
stuff back then so obviously I miss
interacting with those guys every day
and uh you know it's like they said it's
it's good to have somebody to kind of
crack the whip at you every day uh and
John John was very good at that when
you're like younger in your teenage
years you can kind of you like have to
get humbled right there's like a process
to that yeah for sure and uh it's a
pretty good room to get humbled in I
guess yeah exactly I mean I I was uh I
started training with them just when
like everybody started to break out Gary
was like the biggest name at the time uh
just because he had 180 CC trials
already and uh he had a crazy match with
KRON at uh Crown Gracie at ADCC but
Eddie was just starting to break out
Gordon just started winning ebi so I I
started training under John you know
right when when everything was exploding
what are the good things about life
about Jiu Jitsu you learn from your
brother both me and my brother never
really wanted to you know work a
full-time job doing something that we
hate
um and he was always you know a very
confident person so he just went you
know full fully started pursuing Jiu
Jitsu
um so I'm very happy that you know he
did that and I ended up following in his
footsteps because you can ask these guys
I'm a lazy sack of [__] out of outside
of the the uh the mat uh so that's
that's definitely one thing that uh I'm
very grateful for
that he paved the way like you can you
can make money doing stuff you love yeah
exactly and he was he was a big reason
you know why my parents uh eventually
let me drop out of school because you
know when when they were coming up there
was there's no money in the sport it was
very hard to make a full living like if
you wanted to actually make a living
you'd eventually have to transfer to MMA
and I feel like Gordon and Gary and
those guys were you know some of the
first people to make a very good living
off of Just Jiu Jitsu but this part of
you find it heartbreaking
that you've split up from DDs but also
from your brother in terms of spending
time in the mat every day yeah for sure
you know I mean growing up you know
obviously he's my big brother I looked
up to him a lot uh so I definitely like
I said I miss interacting with those
guys I was pretty much raised you know
in that blue basement you know that John
was like you know a father figure to me
um so I definitely you know miss miss
seeing those guys every day do you have
animosity towards Gordon and does he
have animosity toward you and uh what is
the source of that and do you think
you'll ever be able to forgive each
other
definitely initially during the uh the
initial split we definitely hated each
other at the beginning
um but it's definitely started to uh to
calm down actually just prior to you
know all this social media drama that's
going on currently
he had reached out to me and I was
literally like the first time that we
have actually talked since uh since the
split happened so we didn't talk to each
other for was it now like almost two
years
um and that was the first time that you
know we interacted again and um overall
you know he wasn't you know aggressive
towards me I wasn't aggressive towards
him you were cracking some jokes so
hopefully the the animosity is going
down
there's this uh Godfather quote
that wrote down obviously rewatched it
uh from uh from the dawn from Don
Corleone Vito Corleone the strength of a
family like the strength of an army lies
in its loyalty to each other is there
some aspect of family that you miss of
the blood that kind of connects you that
you can count on yeah my parents you
know they both raised us that you know
like family is everything you never you
know betray your family or anything like
that uh so I definitely you know miss
him from time to time okay imagine
you're like 40 years from now
sitting on a porch with a shotgun
drinking whiskey looking over like all
the land you've conquered
looking back to this moment is the
reason you split up a [__] reason
or is it a good reason from the
perspective of the king who has now
conquered the lands have proven himself
have done everything I think it was
definitely like a justifiable reason for
the team splitting like it just with the
way things were going it just was not
going to work with you know all of us in
the same room together it was a started
you know affecting training people
didn't feel comfortable and things like
so I definitely think that it was a
justifiable reason to split
the things that happened in the jungle
yeah to be told about in the book does
it give me an audiobook or is it just
gonna be now who's gonna voice it might
be a play
a musical yeah on Broadway
um how's your singing voice mine's not
so good but Nikki has a beautiful voice
does he of an Angel like a head bet